你还在这上用AI做图吗
写了一长串的提示词
想让AI按照我们的想法来
结果它越画越跑偏
想要生成几张连续的画面
要一张一张的去搞定提示词
再手动的复制粘贴去做图
不仅很麻烦
本质上还要反复抽卡
有一点错误就要全部推倒重来
还没拿到想要的成品
额度已经花光了
但AI终于生成了一张
看起来还行的图
仔细一看
细节却根本经不起推敲
充满了塑料感和AI味
都不好意思发到朋友圈
更别提拿去赚钱了
更令人崩溃的是文字黑洞
它好像根本处理不了大段的文字
动不动就是一堆乱码
每一次修改对方冒着打乱一切的风险
到最后发现实在白费力气
但是今天这些问题都被一个最新的模型解决了
它就是XGPT Images 2.0
它不仅进化出了最强大的理解能力
还能自己思考
并且做到中文高度精准
免费用户也能用
超越了Nano Banana Pro
它把AI圣图已经拉到了一个全新的高度
今天我就带你实操
在GT Images 2.0的八达最新玩法
让你正确打开这个最前沿的王炸生徒模型
所有的提示词我都为你整理好了
记得看到视频结尾找我领取
哈喽大家好
我是银夏
专注研究如何用最新科技
让普通人也能轻松搞钱
博主业里还有更多的AI工具
副业教学
搞钱认知和风头拆解
感兴趣的话可以点个赞订阅我的频道
记得打开小铃铛
这样你就不会错过任何一个
可能改变你生活的机会啦
对了再次介绍一下
作为一个AI领域的创业者
我之前在很多次线下活动里都分享了
怎么用AI做自媒体
打造个人IP
跑通流量闭环
我也在我的AI社区里面分享过
关于不同平台的调性和运营逻辑
我在频道里分享的各种AI稿线玩法
已经带着我们很多的学员时操过
并且拿到了结果
每月稳定变现
如果您想知道
当下最强的生徒模型具体可以怎么用
有哪些最新玩法和惊人的效果
那就一起看下去吧
第一个漫画分镜
其实AI生成漫画已经不是什么新鲜事了
但是之前的AI漫画
需要我们先规划好每一页的内容
角色分别有哪些故事
以及他们各自的台词
做一张四公格的漫画还是有点麻烦的
如果想要连载
更要花很多的时间来慢慢写提示词
一张一张的生成
偶尔也会出现文字乱码的现象
抽卡全靠运气
那今天的Images 2.0模型表现怎么样呢
我们一起看一看
首先打开XGPT
在加号这里面选择Create Image
这里写一段简单的提示词
比如Chikawa和小巴迷路掉进了银翼杀手般的未来城市
到处都是迷红灯
中文招牌和精密机械
请你画出四页漫画
情节连贯完整
中文正确
其实我只是给了XGPT一个想法而已
连具体的情节和脚本都没有写
让它自己去发挥了
跑完了
故事的开始是Chikawa和小巴在散步时不小心走进了奇怪的隧道
画面里写着未来都市
网上人服务
整体氛围感真的很棒
有种赛博朋克的风格
第二幕里发光的牌子上
还有很多中文都正确显示出来了
第三幕他们来到了老王维修铺
最后没有找到回家的路
我觉得画得很不错
不论是对话框里的中文
还是画面里内嵌的中文都没有问题
不得不说真的是进步了
他还给了我第二个方案
风格和故事的走向都不太一样
在这个版本里
梁小智依然来到了未来都市
画风偏手绘
有一只AI机器猫出现
帮他们找到了回家的路
这两个版本我都很喜欢
Images 2.0真的既能思考
又会创作
文字也准确
我还尝试让它一次性生成了四页漫画
每一页都有四宫格
相当于是一次性画出16张图
看看它的能力究竟怎么样
它真的能按照我的想法一次性完成所有内容
文字更多了
但是一点都没有乱码
每个字都是正确的
故事也连关顺畅
真的很不错
第二个IP海报
不知道你有没有看过这样的海报呢
不仅精美大气
还丝化融合了IP相关的很多元素
比如这张塞尔达传说的海报
最引人注目的就是主角林克的侧脸
在它的身上融入了很多塞尔达IP的游戏元素
比如说大师之剑 海浪的王国 守护者 反派盖农等等
而且非常细腻 文字部分也完全正确 挑不出一点毛病
以前想要做出这种水平的海报
至少需要花高价外包给专业的设计师并且要等一两周才能完成但是现在有Images 2.0你在5分钟内就能拿到一个自己制作的大式海报打开GPT这里我的提示词制
甄嬛传收藏版实时海报
人物侧脸剪影中生长出完整世界观与经典场景
整体片电影海报加上梦幻水彩插画风
安静宏大神圣怀旧
自然融入签名零下
这是他给我的结果
我真的震惊了
这也太厉害了吧
各种的细节氛围场景都特别到位
人物和装造简直跟距离差不多
非常精致
还有下雪的故宫
宫殿里的走廊
如果不是我自己把它生成的
我甚至会觉得这幅海报是甄嬛传游戏的宣发图
简直太棒了
后面我还生成了星路谷物语的海报
非常漂亮
元素都正确
还有黑神化悟空的海报
EPS2.0真的好强大
第三个色彩测试图
色彩测试是在韩国很火的一项服务
简单来说就是帮你找到最适合你肤色和气质的颜色组合
包括衣服 妆容 发色等等
按照正确的色彩来做搭配
可以凸显气质 轻松变美
这项服务定价几百到上千不等
很多人专门飞到韩国去做这项测试
但是现在Images 2.0竟然悄无声息的
把真相服务的门槛给抹平了
只需要用到这段提示词上传一张你自己的照片
ChangePT就会马上给你一整套的色彩测试结果
首先他推荐适合我的服装颜色
普通效果和应该避免的颜色
我用了第二段提示词
来生成完整的个人色彩分析报告
他说适合我的整体色彩类型
是明亮温暖清透
给出了最佳色盘
适合与不适合的暗粒
还有建议的妆容穿搭
发型甚至是美甲的颜色
不得不说真的好专业
这样一份色彩报告
以前至少要去专业的机构里面
花上半天的时间
一点一点的来测试
但是现在用ChangePT
三分钟就能拿到结果
是不是很爽呢
后面我还试着
让他生成了妆容的分析报告
真的太好玩了
这几个建议的颜色确实是我平时爱用的颜色
想不到拆GPT在色彩搭配方面也这么专业
如果你是男生
可以用这段提示词来让他给你推荐适合的发型
比如这里我生成了一张男性的图片
GPT提供了详细的发型指南
推荐的 普通的和不建议的
如果你想试试
记得看到视频结尾找我领取提示词
第四个 电商详情图
AI电商图虽然已经不是新闻了
但是一键直出信息密度极高的详情页
并且一次做到所有文字全部正确的AI并不多
即使是Nano Banana Pro
也没有办法在小字上做到100%的准确
但是Images 2.0这次真的给了我惊喜
首先我给它的是一张随手拍的照片
这是我前段时间在哥本哈根旅游时买的纪念品
我的提示词就是非常简单的一句话
请你生成这款产品的电商详情图片
它给我的结果实在出乎意料
首先它识别到这是丹麦卫兵的摆件
选择了干净大方的背景和红白配色
完整精细的把摆件抠图又美化了
标出了产品亮点
还放大了细节图太厉害了
后面还有场景推荐
产品完全正确
看起来非常真实
最后文案写的是
把北欧童话感带回家
说实话
这个水平真的不亚于专业的电商详情页了
可以说在Images 2.0面前
做电商图的门槛几乎消失了
你不需要有任何的设计基础
更不需要会摄影
只要会用AI一张随手拍的图片
也能秒变专业感满满的高级电商图
是不是很棒呢
这里我又给了他一张相机的照片
跟他说
请你奢成这款产品的详情页图片
包括这款相机的参数
应用场景等详细信息
我是想看看
他对于大量的文字
能做到什么样的效果
这个效果真的很让我震惊
首先特别专一
产品图和主要的卖点非常突出
下面是具体的产品亮点
全画幅
高速对焦
视频创作
便携稳定
产品参数这里真的把我惊呆了
我并没有在提示词里面
给他写任何具体的信息
这些全都是他自己想的
从表格的设计到具体内容
真的挑不出毛病
再看看下面的产品细节和使用场景
所有的图片全部基于一张参考图生成
真的好厉害
哪怕是最小最小的字都没有乱码
整张详情页的文字全部正确
对于AI来说
这真的太不容易了
放在以前
想要做出一张这么多信息的电商图
需要一张一张的先去做每一个小图
并且每张图里具体有什么信息都要告诉AI不然AI就会没有编辑的乱发挥最后再把小图拼成一张大图虽然也不算是特别难但是真的很麻烦现在拆GPP Images 2.0
简直是一年压级别的
所有的繁琐流程都已经消失
打几个字就能拿到精美又准确的电商图
真的太棒了
赶紧去试试
第五个小红书图文
你可能已经在小红书上刷得过这样的图文
基本上一眼就能看出来是AI做的
但是依然能收获几千上万的点赞
因为用户喜欢的是内容的价值
并不在意是否是AI生成的
以前想要做出一组这样的图文
需要先规划好每一张图里的内容
去挨个写提示词
再手动生成
或者搭建工作流
但是门槛比较高
大部分普通人都不能快速上手
但是我刚刚发现
ChashGPT Images 2.0
竟然可以用一句话的提示词
直接输出可以发到小红书上面的图文
而且是一次性直出一整套素材
特别棒
我这里用的提示词是
请你生成多张比例为3比4的小红书图文
讲解AI Agent背后的逻辑
稍微等待一会儿
效果简直惊艳
Images 2.0
直接给了我包括封面在内的8张图
风格一致
文字准确
内容连贯
并且很有价值感
第一页是封面
用大字报的方法抓住用户的注意力
主标题AI Agent背后的逻辑
副标题
为什么它不只是一个会聊天的AI
下面是核心内容摘要
任务拆解
工具调用
自动执行
下面是一篇讲庆原理
适合新手入门
配图也很好看
不知道你们看到这个封面是什么样的感受
我觉得大部分没有设计基础的
普通人手动去做
都做不出这样的封面
AI真的太强了
无声无息就帮我们
把层性很高的设计门槛给抹平了
我们一次看看后面的内容
首先讲了什么是AI Agent
下一页是AI Agent和核心组成
以及它到底怎么工作的
还有Agent和拆报的区别
为什么Agent突然火了
哪些任务最适合Agent
和想搭一个Agent要注意的四点
完整看起来
我觉得内容是循序渐进的
而且都是用大白话讲
对于新手小白来说
看懂这篇图文并没有什么难度
这个内容的价值感很足
从介绍最基本的概念
到应该怎么用都讲得很清楚
整篇风格统一
没有一个错字或者输烂码
这个新模型真的太优秀了
原本需要至少一小时才能搞定的图文
现在只需要一句话
Images 2.0就可以在三分钟之内
给你可以直接发的整套图
这样的实力真的形成了新的降维打击
不管是什么主题
只要你想得到
AI都能帮你做出来
真的太神奇了
一定要去亲自试一试
第六个解读复杂知识
除了上面这些
Images 2.0
还有很多有用的玩法
比如它可以帮我们迅速理解复杂的知识
这里我打开了Cloud官方的GitHub
想看看官方出的Skills
都哪些对我有用
我对于这个做PPT的Skill很感兴趣
点开发现
这些文档诠释大量的文字和解释
我觉得很枯燥
不想自己看
那这时我打开ChEHPT
让它给我用图来讲
提示词是
请你帮我用一张图
解读Cloud Code官方的PPT Skill架构
参考链接附上
车会等待一会儿
它就给我出图了
标题是Cloud Code官方PPT Skills架构图写
首先第一层是Skill的触发层
什么时候调用
然后这个Skill三条核心路径是什么
每一条具体都有哪些操作
所匹配的脚本
还有Q&A闭环
自己进行内容和视觉检查
最后是底层视觉设计的逻辑
不要做无聊PPT
拒绝满页白底
项目符号
配色
版式主题等等
都有自己的规定
真的好强
整篇看起来文字全部清晰正确
而且Skill拆解的非常清楚
再也不用自己花时间去读那些无聊的项目文档了
直接让ChayGPT用一张图教会你
这种感觉是不是很爽呢
如果有帮助记得点个赞
第七个品牌素材
这是我上个星期去吃小龙虾时随手拍的一张照片
这是我用一句话提示词让ChayGPT生成的宣传海报
真的把我惊呆了
这也太专业了吧
我的提示词非常简单
就是生成一张宣传海报长图
它给我的成品简直大大的超出了预期
合适的标题背景核心卖点人气招牌
简直就像是专业的设计师熬了几个大业才教出来的图
有点不敢相信
AI竟然一两分钟就能搞定
我还让它生成了垫面图
既精致又充满了烟火气
就像是街边的那种小龙虾店
甚至有点真假难辨了
还有菜单是不是很震惊呢如打菜品各个口味的小龙虾凉菜主食饮品不敢相信这就是我一句话做出来的更加离谱的是我让它生成铲皮礼盒
这是它给我的结果
真的太震撼了
我都没想到礼盒里面是什么样子的
它直接给出了答案
真的特别真实
礼盒里面有一包小龙虾
酱料
两包配菜
甚至连具体的配菜种类
都跟我真实吃的那道菜是一样的
Images 2.0的理解和思考能力
简直太绝了
他首先知道礼盒是什么样的
应该怎么包装
其次他理解了这道菜里的必备食材
正确的打包成了一个完整的礼盒
又做了全套设计
而这一切只用了不到三分钟
更抽象的是
我让他做一张大众点评的截图
真的太离谱了
我的老字号龙虾馆上了大众点评必吃饱
评分4.8好评如潮
地址菜品价格评分
看起来都太真实了
甚至还有用户的评价
每一条都不一样
照片也不一样
我还能领券
在线买单
团购等等
现在的AI实在是太厉害了
第八个生成图鉴
Images 2.0还有一个很强大的玩法
就是生成图鉴
以前想让AI做一张有大量文字的图
也不是不能实现
只是基本上都会遇到小字乱码
信息错位等等问题
但是今天拆GPT把这些问题全都解决了
这就是我用一句话生成的欧洲文艺复兴图鉴
简直太好看了
如果不是我自己把它生成的
我甚至会怀疑这是哪一本百科全书的一页
设计精美 知识准确
文字更是丝毫不差
整幅图就是一个复古的欧式油画
这样的图件让设计师续作
最起码也要好几天
现在就是动动手指的事
我还生成了24级系穿搭指南
仪式词依然很简单
这是他给我的结果
真是绝了
每个小人都是手回风
穿搭合理 设计精美
整体特别清新好看
而且这么大密度的中文
他竟然写的全对
我还试着让他给我画了一个世界咖啡图件
真的太好玩了
简直停不下来
这张咖啡图鉴太精美了
讲了世界咖啡产地
基础知识
怎么处理
烹培度和风味特点
经典咖啡图鉴
如何找到适合自己的
下方的手绘
全是跟咖啡相关的元素
画得太好了
你能想象吗
如果是人工去制作一张
同等标准的插画
要花多少时间
多少钱呢
现在XGPT
不仅能够几分钟的完成
甚至不用花钱
这里你可以尽情的发挥想象
让XGPT帮你一键实现
我又做了有颗里里图鉴
解答了太多的小白问题
古希腊众神图鉴
全部丝滑生成
没有一点难度
如果你想自己去试一试的话
记得给我点个赞
HPT Images 2.0
最新8个玩法都分享给你了
即是在AI越来越强大的今天
所有人都能通过这些AI助手
在几秒钟内生成一张完美的海报
写一段流畅的脚本
甚至是部署一个全能的agent
技术早就不是壁垒了
以前的护生盒
可能是你会用PS
你会写代码
或者你有一支能熬夜的设计团队
但在2026年
这些曾经引以为傲的技术硬实力
正在像水和电一样
变成只要付钱就能买到的基础资源
AI确实抹平了技术上的差距
但是它无法抹平思维上的差距
如果你只是把AI当成一个更快的搬砖工具
只会陷入新一轮的价格战
因为你能生成的别人也能生成
在这个生产利益平权的时代
最应该思考的不是你到底能生成什么
而是作为创作者
到底怎么样用更低的成本去创造更高的价值
你能不能看懂用户情绪
能不能定义品牌质感
能不能在海量素材里面
挑出最能让你变现的那个
AI可以代替我们动手
但是无法代替我们动脑
它没有办法决定什么才是好的
如果你觉得这些内容有帮助
现在就做三件事
第一点赞收藏这个视频
并且分享给你的朋友
这样大数据也会记得你
给你推送更多类似的
有价值的内容
第二订阅我的频道
并且打开小铃铛
我会持续分享更多AI搞钱的实战方法
第三也是最重要的
打开XGPT
马上开始尝试images2.0
就现在不要拖
也欢迎在评论区告诉我
你最想尝试今天的哪个玩法
你在AI变形上遇到的最大困惑是什么
你还想了解哪些AI创业话题
我会根据大家的反馈制作出更多的实战视频
记得找我领取本期视频的提示词手册
添加我的微信作为界面里送给你哈
我是宁夏
这个频道是专注研究如何用最新科技
让普通人也能轻松搞钱
记得点击订阅打开小铃铛
我们下期见啦